in Hollandaise you also write during the
19th and 20th centuries as humanism
gained increasing social credibility and
political power it sprouted two very
different offshoots socialist humanism
which encompassed a plethora of
socialist and communist movements and
evolutionary humanism whose most famous
Advocates were the Nazis so if you can
just Linger on that what's the
ideological connection between Nazism
and communism as embodied by humanism
and humanism basically is you know the
focus is on humans that they are the
most important thing in the world they
move history
but then there is a big question what is
what are humans what is humanity
now liberals
they place at the center of the story
individual humans and they don't see
history as a kind of necessary Collision
between big forces they place the
individual at the center if you want to
know you know there is a bed
especially in the US today liberal is
taking taken as the opposite of
conservative
but it's to test whether you're liberal
you need to answer just three questions
very simple uh do you think people
should have the right to choose their
own government or uh the government
should be imposed by some outside force
uh do you think people should have the
right to the Liberty
to choose their own profession or either
born into some cause that predetermines
what they do and do you think people
should have the Liberty to choose their
own spouse and their own way of personal
life instead of being told by Elders or
parents who to marry and how to live
now if you answered yes to all three
questions people should have the Liberty
to choose their government their
profession their personal lives their
spouse then you're a liberal
and most conservatives are also liberal
now Communists and fascists they answer
differently
for them history is not yes history is
about humans humans are the big heroes
of history but not individual humans and
their liberties
fascists imagine history as a clash
between races or nations the nation is
at the center
they say the Supreme good is the good of
the nation you should have a hundred
percent loyalty only to the nation
you know liberals say yes you should be
loyal to the nation but it's not the
only thing
there are other things in the world that
human rights there is truth there is
beauty
many times yes you should prefer the
interests of your nation over other
things but not always
if your nation tells you to murder
millions of innocent people you don't do
that even though the nation tells you to
do it
um when to to lie for the national
interest you know in extreme situations
maybe but in many cases your loyalty
should be to the truth
even if it makes your nation looks a bit
not no not in the best light the same
with beauty you know how does the
fascist determine whether a movie is a
good movie very simple if it serves the
interests of the nation this is a good
movie if it's against the interest of
the nation this is a bad movie end of
story liberalism says no there is a
aesthetic values in the world
uh we should judge movies not just on
that question whether they serve the
national interest but also on autistic
value
Communists are a bit like the fascists
instead that they don't place the nation
at the main Euro they Place class as the
main hero for them history again it's
not about individuals it's not about
Nations history is the clash between
classes and just as fascists imagine in
the end only one nation will be on top
the Communists think in the end only one
class should be on top and that's the
the proletariat and same story The your
a hundred percent of your loyalty should
be to the class
and like if you if there is a clash
there between class and family class
wins like in the Soviet Union the party
told children if you hear your parents
say something bad about Stalin you have
to report them and there are many cases
when children reported their parents and
their parents were sent to the gulag
like and you know your loyalty is to the
party to the which leads the proletariat
to victory in the historical struggle
and the same way in communism art is
only about class struggle a movie is
good if it serves the interest of the
target artistic values there is nothing
like that and the same with truth
the everything that we see now in fake
news uh you know the Communist
propaganda machine was there before us
the level of of of of lies of this
information campaigns that they
orchestrated in the 1920s and 30s and
40s is is really an unimaginable
so the reason these two ideologies
classes of ideologies failed is the
sacrifice of Truth
and that just failed but did a lot of
damage as sacrifice the truth and
sacrifice of beauty and sacrifice of
hundreds of millions of people disregard
even for human suffering like okay for
in order to for our nation to win in
order for our class to win we need to
kill those Millions kill those Millions
that that was in ethics Aesthetics uh
truth they don't measure the only thing
that matter is the victory of the state
or the victory of the class and that and
liberalism was the antithesis to that it
says no not only it's uh it it it has a
much more complicated view of the world
and growth communism and fascist they
had a very simple view of the world
there is one uh uh your loyalty 100 of
it should be only to one thing
now liberalism has a much more complex
view of the world it says yes there are
nations they are important yes there are
classes they are important but they are
not the only thing there are also
families there are also
um individuals there are also animals
and your loyalty should be divided
between all of them sometimes you prefer
this sometimes you prefer that that's
complicated
and but you know life is complicated but
also I think uh maybe you can correct me
but liberalism acknowledges the
corrupting nature of power when there's
a guy at the top sits there for a while
managing things uh is probably gonna
start losing
um a good sense of reality and
losing the capability to be a good
manager it feels like the uh Communists
and uh fascist regimes don't acknowledge
that basic uh characteristic of human
nature that power corrupts yes they
believe in infallibility yeah
uh they're in in this sense they're very
close to being a religions
the in Nazism Hitler was considered
infallible and therefore you don't need
any checks and balances on his power why
do you need to balance an infallible
genius and it's the same with the Soviet
Union in style with Stalin and more
generally with the with the Communist
Party The Party can never make a mistake
and therefore you don't need independent
quotes Independent Media opposition
parties things like that because then
party is never wrong you concentrate
some way a hundred percent of loyalty
should be to the party a hundred percent
of power should be in the hands of the
party the whole idea of liberal
democracy is embracing fallibility
everybody is fallible all people or
leaders or political parties or
institutions this is why we need checks
and balances and we need many of them if
you have just one then this particular
check itself could make terrible
mistakes so you need to say a a you need
a press
you need the media to serve as a check
to the government you don't have just
one newspaper or one TV station you need
many
so that they can balance each other and
the media is not enough so if you have
independent quotes you have free
academic institutions you have ngos you
have a lot of checks and balances